well the blight and the chestnut the
farmers was a guest not he keeps
smouldering at the roots and sending out
new shoots til another parasite shall
come to end the blight at the beginning
of the 20th century the eastern American
chestnut population counting nearly four
billion stre was completely decimated by
a fungal infection fungi are the most
destructive pathogen of plan including
crop of major economic importance can
you imagine that today crop losses
associated to fungal infection are
estimated to billion of dollars per year
worldwide that represent enough food
calories to feed half a billion people
and this lead to severe repercussions
including episodes of famine in
developing countries large reduction of
income for farmers and distributors high
prices for consumers and risk of
exposure to mycotoxin poison produced by
fungi the problem that we face is that
the current method used to prevent and
treat those dreadful diseases such as
genetic control exploiting natural
sources of resistance crop rotation or
see treatment among others are still
limited or ephemeral they have to be
constantly renewed therefore we urgently
need to develop more efficient
strategies and for this research is
required to identify biological
mechanism that can be targeted by novel
antifungal treatments one feature of
fungi is that they cannot move and only
grow by extension to form a
sophisticated Network the mycelium in
1884 Anton Debray the father of plant
pathology was the first to presume that
fungi are guided by signals sent out
from the host plant meaning a plan upon
which it can lodge and subsist so
signals at
lighthouse for fungi to locate grow the
word rich and finally invade and
colonize the plant he knew that the
identification of such signals would
unlock a great knowledge set themselves
to elaborate strategy to block the
interaction between the fungus and the
plant however the lack of appropriate
method at that moment prevented him for
identifying this mechanism at a
molecular level using purification and
mutational genomic approaches as well as
a technique allowing the measurement of
directed - gross today I'm glad to tell
you that after 130 years my former team
and I could finally identify such plant
signals by studying the interaction
between a pathogenic fungus called
physio Moxie sperm and one of its host
plant the tomato plant as well we could
characterize the fungal receptor
receiving those signals and part of the
underlying reaction occurring within the
fungus and leading to its direct goes
toward the plant thank you
the understanding of such molecular
process of a panel of potential
molecules that can be used to create
novel antifungal treatments and those
treatment would disrupt the interaction
between the fungus and the plant either
by blocking the plant signal or the
fungal reception system which receives
those signals fungal infection has
devastated agriculture crop moreover we
are now in an era where the demand of
crop production is increasing
significantly and this is due to
population growth economic development
climate change and demand for biofuels
our understanding of the molecular
mechanism of interaction between a
fungus and its host plant such as a
tomato plant potentially represent a
major step toward developing more
efficient strategy to combat plant
fungal diseases and therefore solving of
problems that affects people's life food
security and economic growth thank you
[Applause]